la justice va-t-elle enfin solder le
passé de la sphère smoby et de son ex
pdg jean christophe breuil
lundi le tribunal correctionnel de nancy
spécialisée dans les affaires
financières rendra sa décision
concernant l'ancien patron de smoby et
cinq cadres ou anciens collaborateurs de
l'entreprise en octobre dernier pendant
sept jours
la justice avait décortiqué les montages
financiers souvent opaques qui lient à
ces professionnels du jouet jean
christophe breuil est soupçonné d'abus
de biens sociaux de blanchiment et
détournement de fonds
près de 10 millions d'euros grâce à des
sociétés écrans installés dans des
paradis fiscaux ce qui s'est passé c'est
que
on se rend compte qu'une personne qui a
pris des bonbons dans le sac et puis qui
les a cachés dans un autre sac pour que
les gens voient aussi simple que ça pour
jean christophe breuil le procureur
avait requis quatre ans de prison dont
trois ans et demi avec sursis ainsi que
la confiscation de 5 millions d'euros
une somme correspondant à un chalet dans
les alpes et des contrats d'assurance
vie invisible pendant le procès mais
représentés par leurs avocats
les parties civiles des dizaines
d'actionnaires qui réclame des
réparations
smoby cotées en bourse n'avait pas
transmis les bonnes informations sur sa
santé financière
tout ce que je sais c'est que la société
dépose le bilan et les millions investis
par mes clients ont disparu purement et
simplement
enfin il y a le volet social de cette
affaire la liquidation judiciaire de ce
maudit et les 800 emplois supprimés en
france
la cgt demande elle aussi des
réparations onze ans après la fin du
numéro 1 français du jouet l'heure des
comptes a sonné l'ancien pdg qui
travaillent en suisse et à hong kong ne
devrait pas être incarcéré il a déjà
effectué six mois de prison en 2008